what's an actor's best friend and worst
enemy in terms of
not only their career but also their
creativity
well i think you know their their
worst enemy let's start with that is you
know the insecurity the insecurity can
make you doubt
and when you doubt you might not
deliver your best work
and
you know your best friend is that you
are
you stay hooked up with the part of
yourself
that has something that wants to say you
know the part of you that wants to
express something
emotionally you know it's the why you as
an actor choose to be in this profession
to begin with the answer to that why
i think remains continues to be your
best friend
oh that's excellent
in terms of the career path like even
day to day
you know what they do
worst enemy
best friend in terms of looking for work
networking whatever it is right well
worst enemy obviously is procrastination
you know and not
delaying
getting sidetracked by life or
other things
and
yeah whatever
and uh you know and the best friend is
you know your willingness
to
keep expressing yourself your
willingness to
to be playful
because
if you embrace the playfulness inside of
you you know the wonder child the child
in you that wants to play then you will
turn
every experience that you have in acting
as an actor as something that was just a
joy fun
you